hey what's going on it's bill burr it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday April 9 2018 how the [ __ ] are you
doing huh that's good that's good I just
got back from Cincinnati or as they call
it the natty the night before I was in
Pittsburgh or as they call it the burg
about a year ago this time I was in
Cleveland or as they call it the land
I've always wanted to do a gig in Akron
or as they call it the Ron what is with
that part of the [ __ ] country
what is st. Louis they call it the Louis
the Louis a welcome to the Louie hey
welcome to the walkie welcome to the
inner knots of state Minnesota many
idiota
welcome to the appleís welcome to the
Paul no it only works with the Berg the
nati the land and I'll bill per the
douche and when we return we're going to
be discussing the upturn in the stock
market you know it's funny I didn't give
him [ __ ] about that at all I didn't even
think about that the whole time I was
there I was ill I was too [ __ ] tired
I flew in Thursday night so I could get
up early the next day and go to WD dei
with Randy and Bill and I went in there
Ian bagg sitting there like the [ __ ]
headliner he is and there's Joe part
Nick and we had a great time and I
evidently I said [ __ ] twice and I
said [ __ ] once I knew when I said [ __ ]
does everyone oh and I'm such a
foul-mouthed freckled jerk-off I didn't
even realize I did it I felt bad
whatever I had a good time so I want to
thank Randy a bill for having me in all
these years that's why I sell tickets
and
burg Pittsburgh was a very difficult
ticket to sell for a long [ __ ] time
you know I used to work that goddamn
cavernous improv it's not a comedy club
it's not a theater it's just a giant
like they should have a [ __ ] DJ in
there well those big rooms with no
chairs right and the guys just starts
spinning and everybody's on [ __ ]
drugs whatever it is they do actually
you know I've seen some of those DJs
lately I've seen some of those YouTube
videos and you they have little Casio
keyboards you know to add to their beats
do you think it's harder to play drums
with just your little fingers than
actually play drums you know what I'm
getting sick of I'm getting sick of the
one-man band guy you know when they got
that little [ __ ] thing where they
they do they do a drum beat first then
they add the bass and then they yell
some [ __ ] and then they [ __ ] do
something else I mean how many people
are gonna do that [ __ ] act all right
it's like I get it you have no friends
you know it's like the baseball kid for
a musician the whole point of making
music is to go do it with other [ __ ]
people look if you're doing it at a high
[ __ ] level I don't mind but there's a
lot of people on YouTube who are just
gonna yeah okay okay and then they hit
the thing and then they just stand there
and they can still hear his voice going
boom yeah
I know somebody gonna turn this into a
song so I'm not gonna make the rest of
the [ __ ] noises alright you probably
just used to like the part of the
podcast oh maybe that laughter put that
over the top right and then add your own
stuff and then you have a [ __ ] there
you go they make make a podcast deep or
whatever the [ __ ] I was just doing every
time everybody flips the [ __ ] out like
holy [ __ ] I can't believe they just did
that it's like musicians have been doing
that for years haven't they
I remember Steven Tyler way back in the
day when they had them making a pump he
was on every [ __ ] instrument in there
I guess because we never saw it I don't
know what I'm talking about this is what
I never I try not to do podcasts on days
that I flew on an airplane because I
feel like for me they're never funny
they're always [ __ ] scatterbrained oh
man we got me and bartnick drove from
[ __ ] uh since and I'm from Pittsburgh
over to Cincinnati I thought like a
three-hour drive I always forget like
that [ __ ] the conehead part of West
Virginia is in between that part of
Pennsylvania in Ohio and I'll tell you
Matt I feel [ __ ] life of me I do not
understand the poverty of that state
Pennsylvania's doing fine Ohio's doing
fine and you just drive through that
little [ __ ] Triangle on the 70 I was
joking on stage you're on you're driving
by on the highway and you look off you
see people like wave and ask him for
help you know what I mean like [ __ ]
Willem Dafoe and in platoon such a
gorgeous state I don't get it I don't
know I think one day that that place
that place is going to turn around the
way downtown Cincinnati did I remember
10 years ago I did that funny bone
that's just across the [ __ ] river the
Ohio River in Cincinnati I was in
Kentucky and I stayed there like you
want to stay out in the Kentucky areas
like nah now I want to stay in downtown
Cincinnati won't be downtown where we're
we're [ __ ] is happening now was that 10
years ago and it was one of these
[ __ ] towns man everybody comes into
work at 8:00 and at 5:00 everybody
leaves and it's you're you're alone
there's nobody there there's homeless
people there's people who need medical
mental assistance you know crazy people
and all the stores is [ __ ] closed up
you got to get your last meal by three
o'clock are you [ __ ] and I had been
that I feel it feels like forever
and
I I mean the downtown airs it's [ __ ]
amazing [ __ ] him is actually a whole
article the second I got there was like
this is not the Cincinnati that I
remember from that [ __ ] gig and that
I carried with me the next two times
even though it was slowly getting better
I had such a bad experience the first
time but actually people write in
[ __ ] articles on it where the hell is
it bill there you go Cincinnati
streetcar they got a [ __ ] streetcar
okay by the time the first passengers
boarded Cincinnati streetcar in
September its advocates had already been
on a wild 15 year ride that included
surviving two ballot initiatives to
derail the project whatever I'm not
reading all this boring [ __ ] they got
all this [ __ ] cool stuff to do down
there though and evidently I was talking
this guy in the plane they revitalized a
bunch of bad areas but they didn't kick
the people out now this was according to
a white male in first class so who knows
who knows what happens because that's
what I'd like to see done you know have
that done and for poor white people to I
never understand what it's just like oh
we're making this area better it's like
what about the people that were there
they would have made it better if they
had any [ __ ] money I don't understand
why like the areas like that at this
point you know we're doing all these
startups and all of this [ __ ] we ought
to do it for our own [ __ ] countrymen
shouldn't we then every place is nice
everywhere you go is a nice little
[ __ ] cupcake area or whatever I don't
know do you think then everything would
be the same because you already had that
[ __ ] problem you know there has to be
a way to go into different neighborhoods
of people and [ __ ] help out broke-ass
people yet they still they don't lose
their vibe you know the music the food
the people the whole [ __ ] thing
because what's like I don't know let's
once what's the [ __ ] people they want
what's why people come in then it just
becomes white you know it's good
know what I'm talking about right now I
just don't understand West Virginia it's
[ __ ] gorgeous I don't know why people
don't want to is it's being a minor the
only [ __ ] job is that why you know
there's either people there mining isn't
that [ __ ] honey boo boo from there
[ __ ] dirt floor cabin she grew up in
it's one of the saddest things ever I
tried to watch that show one [ __ ]
time and they were going down the
grocery store and they were having an
auction on food that was at the grocery
store that they no longer could legally
sell but they weren't even buying [ __ ]
that at least he used to be healthy like
perishable [ __ ] like fruits and
vegetables which God knows what the [ __ ]
they sprayed it with right they won't
they will [ __ ] bidding on like double
stuffed Oreo cookies it's like they've
already expired and they're not good for
you and she's sitting there looking like
haystack Calhoun I mean what what what
the [ __ ] do you went out here's a
question what do you do with that you
know what I mean that's just like I mean
it's just a [ __ ] show and it already
[ __ ] procreated so now you got half
of that and somebody else maybe they'll
be half as stupid maybe some smart
person got drunk and [ __ ] her that's
the best thing you can hope for and
knock down her stupid by 50% right cuz
certain people you see they're broken
you just like alright well maybe if they
had some opportunity then there's other
people it's just like now you know even
if she was born rich I just don't then
once the parents died I think I don't
see that fortune surviving
let's look up honey [ __ ] boo boo
honey boo boo was the mom
no that was the kid honey boo boo mother
come on internet
mama June mama June of here comes honey
boo boo famous for raising Paget
prisoners Papa Papa
where the [ __ ] is she from amazing
weight loss Jesus Christ you know what
people are really fat and they lose all
that weight then they gotta figure out
what they're gonna do with the skin I
think then they need to do a startup to
get rid of the skin right I mean Jesus
Christ you'd need an extra start up just
for this [ __ ] underneath her chin she
has that unfortunate thing where it like
you know it's like your chin is flush
with your chest and she's way too young
to have that level of a double chin and
that's what happens people when you go
down to the grocery store because you're
so [ __ ] broke and you have to you have
to bid on already expired double stuffed
Oreo cookies her neck is full of the
cream that's what it is that's
disgusting isn't it but you know what in
this day and age I imagine she's a hero
all right let's let's see her let's see
her loss she lost a bunch of weight good
for her good for her now she's gonna
live longer you know what they should
have done with the facelift they should
also [ __ ] they should have fixed her
I know this is harsh people but there's
too many [ __ ] people there's too much
traffic okay you can't have dumb people
like making more [ __ ] people that are
gonna be out there on the road you know
and that DNA is full of [ __ ] expired
Oreo cookie double stuff you just Giggy
can't [ __ ] do it and this is the
thing that liberals cannot handle and
conservatives go too far with there has
to be a feel-good solution would you do
I would just say listen if you if you're
dumb and you don't have kids the
government will give you Oreo cookies
that have not expired how about that
well start with that as an taxpayers
will pay for that it'll come off the top
right I don't know how to solve this I
don't even know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about I can't tell you this
guess what the [ __ ] I'm doing on April
13th I'm gonna be in [ __ ]
[Music]
North Carolina
at the rough and rowdy and vet event I
cannot [ __ ] wait for this I think I
got the suit that I'm going to wear I'm
very excited and I'm gonna be there it's
gonna be $15.99 if you order now 1999
the day of the event I'm gonna be
commenting the entire night God willing
I'm gonna be there with El Presidente
and the big cat dan dan cats and guess
who's fighting on the card the one man
thrill right all right he's not
wrestling
he's fighting he's not wrestling he's
fighting and he's going to show why he's
an absolute sandwich and I can't [ __ ]
win I'm very excited for this event I
hope I add to it and bring some more
humor to it and check it out sixteen
bucks the [ __ ] do you care what do you
do with you sixteen bucks go down there
bid on some cookies so when he was I had
a great flight back from Cincinnati
congratulations by the way is very
excited for Cincinnati after watching
Pittsburgh they hold downtown area start
to get going again all right Cleveland's
made a huge comeback cincinnati has made
a comeback it's [ __ ] tremendous I
hope this keeps happening because I've
been on the road since the 90s and those
places were really sad and I remember in
2004 when Nick Costas opened hilarities
I remember looking across the street and
talking to one of the comics there
saying if I had money I'd buy that
[ __ ] building right across the street
and it was just like this beautiful
building that was just empty
just [ __ ] empty and and hilarities
were the only lights on on that block
and I would finish my show and the cop
would walk me to my hotel around the
corner to make sure I didn't get jumped
or anything right so and there we are
now like that whole street now is lit up
like the [ __ ] Bullwinkle show and man
if I was where I am now back then I
would have invested in all those that I
wanted to invest in Detroit now that's
[ __ ] coming back to but I still might
do that you know I think that's a great
thing to do by a [ __ ] in an
up-and-coming city that needs and money
in there
I something there and you don't kick the
people out and you give them a nice safe
place you know they're paying rent the
[ __ ] did these [ __ ] [ __ ] they
redo these things and then they kick
everybody out then they try and flip it
you know this [ __ ] heartless [ __ ]
that'll going to some beautiful building
and just gut the place and come back
with like Home Depot [ __ ] then kick
everybody out and try to get [ __ ] you
know 20 and 30-somethings in there
I don't know I'm against it personally
but then again I never tried to do it
who knows who knows maybe someday I'll
become a slumlord I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm gonna do alright anyways
plowing ahead here so my flight back I
overslept but fortunately the airport
was right down the street and cruise
through security and all that [ __ ] got
there in plenty of time and I get on the
plane and Delta Airlines I always slide
different airline I'm not [ __ ] loyal
to any of them because I never used the
[ __ ] Mouse all right I have no
interest in getting on the phone trying
to figure out you know when I can use
them you know I don't give a [ __ ] keep
keep the [ __ ] miles what am i George
Clooney and that [ __ ] movie up up and
away
up up and away hey with my salt and
pepper perfect [ __ ] hair you know I
love most about that movie I'm gonna
ruin it here his when he finally finds
love and he comes and he finds out that
woman's married and she looks at him
like get the [ __ ] out of here he has to
get the [ __ ] out here that was one of
the realest things I've seen in a movie
in a while that's how it usually works
out you know something happens so
anyways the why would I say that why
would I why would I put that sort of
negativity out there because I'm a [ __ ]
that's right so I get on the plane and I
made sure I told my wife to take the f1
race from Bahrain and get on the plane
lo and behold I have espn2 and I'm like
holy [ __ ]
the [ __ ] race is coming on at ten
past eleven right so I sit there and I'm
watching [ __ ] ESPN which is hilarious
now you know I mean every sports talk
show now it seems like a woman has to be
like running it and then the guys are
sitting there like she's the teacher now
just like the overcorrection
you don't I mean so now like a guy can't
run a show I don't [ __ ] get it right
so I'm watching this [ __ ] and they show
this woman from the women's hockey team
throwing out the first pitch instead of
throwing out the first pitch she uses a
hockey stick and she takes a [ __ ]
Rishta and sends it to the catcher and
the guy cake comes out of his crotch and
he catches it was a [ __ ] ball by the
way so there's a good woman and a man
commentating on this [ __ ] [ __ ] she
goes see that yeah
you know most you know a lot of the
dudes can't even get it over you know
that's why I've been telling you women
are just better they're just better it
thinks the guy's like hell buddy though
you're gonna say it it's like she goes
that's right you got a wife and a
daughter it was just like what in the
what what the [ __ ] was that just imagine
that conversation and you flipped the
sex the guy's saying it to her hey you
see that most of broads can't get it
over the plate guys are just better at
[ __ ] right I'm not even gonna say
anything that's right you got a husband
and almost slap the [ __ ] out of you you
dumb [ __ ] all right dumb [ __ ] I put a
little bit too much mustard on it but
that's basically what the [ __ ] they said
and then she came back again and she
said it again which is hilarious and I
you see that a lot now and at first it
bothered me then I'm just like this is
actually just it's not coming from a
place of strength it's coming from this
really insecure place like right see we
can do stuff nobody said you kid I guess
they did back in the day but nobody now
is saying that I just like hey know
every guy has to have his tail between
his legs I wish I was commentating
whether I'd be like that's astoundingly
ignorant and reverse sexist what are you
talking about I could [ __ ] do what
she just did if he gave me three tries
it's a [ __ ] wrist shot with a
baseball you got to eat up on a mound
I'll even play hockey I think you give
me five attempts I think I could [ __ ]
do that but you know what's funny is if
I went and I failed that woman would
feel justified because a stand-up
comedian couldn't get a baseball not 90
feet or 45 feet whatever the [ __ ] it is
with a hockey stick that would be
considered a victory I guess I don't
know so then I'm still watching right
and then they have this really weird
commercial you got to see this one I
actually wrote it down on my phone so I
wouldn't forget where am I getting the
notes women are just a pattern it's just
better I was [ __ ] around that this
weekend where they just said they're
going you know the future is female like
all guys are just gonna step aside after
we built everything up we're just gonna
give you the airplanes go [ __ ] yourself
earn them I'm [ __ ] with you ladies
but you know what something here's how
you divide and conquer the cool ones
know what I'm saying all right there's a
commercial out right now that you have
to see for new genic that has the big
hurt in it and I swear to god he's
stand-in there cuz he lost all this
weight and this woman's standing there
with this guy who I assume they're kind
of together right she goes he says
something oh wow is that the big hurt
she says wow he looks yeah that's the
big hurt and she said she should call
him call him like the big handsome or
some she complements on the way he looks
and then the guy rather than being like
[ __ ] he looking at another man for and
commenting it in front of me [ __ ]
disrespect me like that in this grocery
store you know is this something I need
to know instead of saying that he just
goes yeah or you kind of agreed with her
right then they get over there and this
is really weird conversation where
they're talking about this stuff that
helps you lose weight and everything and
subtly makes you [ __ ] better I swear to
God
the way the dialogue went I don't you
know I couldn't write it down fast
enough I thought in the end that dude
was gonna ask big hurt to [ __ ] his wife
[Laughter]
hey listen I don't know it might maybe
it's me maybe it's me maybe all of this
is playful and I just have to Dizzy's to
[ __ ] mind and that's how I'm seeing
this [ __ ] so don't take it seriously all
right
speaking of diseased mind
April I am gonna be no vice Billy no
vice no drinking no smoking cigars no
online porn meditating yoga working out
eating right drinking water all of that
[ __ ] Little House on the Prairie [ __ ]
okay and I am when you hear this I'll be
nine days in all right Oh Billy no vice
hashtag Billy nice nice it'll Billy
boredom what else Oh William without
[ __ ] I'm almost halfway through the
month no I think I'm gonna try to go to
my birthday right I'm gonna go to my
birthday you know get myself you know in
the shape I want to be and so turning 50
you know turning 50 wasn't bugging me
now all of a sudden now that it's like
two months away as of today no as of
Tuesday it's two months away it's
starting to [ __ ] hit me even though I
know I'm not gonna feel any different
it's just that you can kind of lie to
yourself through your 40s that you know
now you know I look good for my age
above you turned 50 you [ __ ] old
you're [ __ ] you're even old to people
that are old like somebody 70 would love
to be 50 but they're not looking at you
like like you know they're not picked
they'll take 50 you know what I mean but
if you know if they've nobody's picking
that age if they rub a genie lamp and a
genie comes out what age do you want to
be nobody's saying 50 even if you're
[ __ ] 120 what's good nobody saying 40
or 30 I don't know anyways so it's been
going good it's been going good I like
not drinking I guess I do but I don't
know you go to Pittsburgh
sparks just a town you just like [ __ ]
man I'm getting drunk how do you not
this is just it's too amazing we wanted
up from aunty brothers however the [ __ ]
you say it you know we went to the place
the Italian market
Bartnik favorite when we gets the gallo
rule right my god I got got all of that
and they just you know was eating that
all [ __ ] weekend stuffed olives I ate
like a [ __ ] lunatic but uh I didn't
eat at night so it wasn't that bad but I
definitely did not eat healthy over the
last couple of [ __ ] days but anyways
but I didn't booze I didn't smoke in
both towns had cigar bars and I had to
walk by them and on the plane ride home
I was watching top 10 tight ends of all
time and they got to Mike Ditka and he
was talking all this [ __ ] and then he
just took you know a [ __ ] you know a
couple of pulls off this fat cigars just
like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] but I'm gonna get
though I'm gonna make it I don't know I
don't know you know what it is it's like
every day I wake up and I don't miss not
doing heroin because I never did it and
that's the thing like they say once you
open the Pandora's box
oh [ __ ] speaking in that [ __ ] you know
that uh you know that's ac/dc song Sin
City and when they do the breakdown boom
boom whatever the [ __ ] I came here but I
can't remember the bass line of that but
boom boom and the kick drums on - which
is weird
and then Bon Scott goes ladders and
snakes that is guild snakes take right
now he's always like what is he saying
that ladders ladders and snakes liars
sounds like he's saying ladders like
something you climb up I never knew what
the [ __ ] it meant but did I tell you
guys to see I can't remember
and Mike Devon told me he goes no it's
it's a he said that's in Australia
that's like shoots and lat
but the original was called ladders and
snakes and then I looked it up it's
actually from India if I'm right and it
has to do with vices and virtues and
it's called snakes and ladders so as you
played sort of the same board game of
chutes and ladders right so you know if
you get on a snake that's a vice and you
slide down if you land on a snake I
should say you slide down but to go in a
ladder that's a virtue and virtues bring
you up so basically you know after years
of sliding down into Vice I'm now gonna
try to go up a couple floors on the
ladder I guess I don't [ __ ] know I
don't know what I'm doing all I know is
every once in a while I got shut down
but every time I have to shut it down
like the window is shorter basic go hide
for ten months and then shut it down for
a month now it's like I go hard for two
three months and then I shut it down for
like four or five I don't know I don't
get it just all the comedy just left at
this [ __ ] podcast it's just it's just
not fun it's not [ __ ] I don't give up
[ __ ] people have you know I [ __ ] love
being sober I love being sober you know
I'm sitting next to this [ __ ] guy
that one of these guys that says yes
that's the worst when you're sober okay
I get you something to drink I'm like
yeah I'll have a water and he goes I'll
have a Bloody Mary like he finishes his
Bloody Mary she goes would you like
another one he's like yeah how about you
sir nah I'm fine with my water I was
just clocking this guy right I flew out
another guy was just like that had a
Jack and Coke that he got the [ __ ]
meal you don't think got another Jack
and Coke and then the lady said hey you
want some ice cream right and he's like
yeah but can I wait she goes yeah then
later he had the ice cream you said yes
the entire [ __ ] flight as I sat down
just have a water anyways
plow ahead by the way that's what you
can look forward to you work your ass
off you sit at the front of the plane
they bring you ice cream like it's a fig
you're a [ __ ] two-year-old
but here's the thing that here's the
thing all right you die sooner cuz
you're up there eating and drinking like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] alright at least if
you're in the back you know what I mean
you back there starving but you're gonna
live longer all right
and the worst thing is to ride up front
and be sober and watching somebody
acting like they're in the [ __ ] Roman
Empire and you're sitting there drinking
[ __ ] waters or eating a sad salad
anyways let me do the food let me do the
[ __ ] uh the reads for the week here
why don't we got here do I have any
advertising left in this well oh the
black tux everybody the black tux like
the Ohio State or the land the nati the
burg
the black tux for more than a year now
I've talked about the black tux calm the
black tux never gets old
because they always have new and
exciting styles for your next big event
ooh look at that lapel hey I like your
cumberbund whether you're going for a
stylistic stylist selected outfit or
building a custom look the black tux has
tons of new suits and tuxedos to choose
from I thought so fat people tons of new
suits and tuxedos to choose from for
your big spring event the black tux
black tux is always changing up their
looks making it fun to try out different
suits and tuxedos even if you have your
own suit switching to v black tux is
always a great idea and with their new
fit algorithm one of the most overly
used [ __ ] words in the English
language or algorithm you know that you
know how they all have a [ __ ]
algorithm because you gave your
information at CVS you got your [ __ ]
retinas scanned at the airport and they
all share the information so now they
have an algorithm and what they have a
[ __ ] 3d model of your goddamn
skeleton they here's what the
mouth-breathing morons says yeah you
know I don't give a [ __ ] as long as it
tuxedo fits Jesus Christ is I think in a
land on my [ __ ] house
the black tux and within whatever fit
algorithm you don't have to awkwardly
measure yourself how is it awkward to
measure yourself see how they were
trying to make it seem more easy just
measure yourself you dumb [ __ ] it's
simple or ask a friend for help that's
when it gets awkward the or I guess you
know it's kind of hard to it's not
awkward it's difficult I see what you're
saying then your roommates a guy and all
of a sudden he's got a measure your
inseam you know in the back of his hands
touching the underneath you ball bag you
know what I take that back thank God you
have an algorithm you know
all right the black tux does it for you
plus the black tux is home Tryon lets
you see the fit and feel the quality of
your suit months before your event I
always think that's dangerous months
before your event you try it on and then
what you [ __ ] go out boozing and
doesn't fit your person you come upon
there after ordering your suit after
ordering your suit we'll all right up I
always blow off commas after ordering
you suit no after ordering your suit
will arrive 14 days before your event
and remember how simple returns are wear
it turn heads then send it back three
days after your event shipping is free
both ways stand out at your event for
the right reason with the black tux wear
it just ship it back good lord I can't
imagine the hazmat suit they're wearing
when they take that thing back during
prom season to get $20 off your purchase
visit the black tux comm slash bird
that's the black tux compr for $20 off
your purchase the black tux comm premium
rental suits and tuxedos delivered
simply safe here's why I'm a big fan of
simply safe home security evidently
simply safe is prepared for anything
that gets thrown at it if a storm takes
out your power simply safe is ready and
intruder cut your phone line simply safe
is ready say they destroy your keypad or
siren simply safe will get you the help
you need they come running up your front
door with a [ __ ] chainsaw on simply
safe it's ready
sure maybe it's overkill maybe you don't
need to be ready for every worst-case
scenario but that's what makes simply
save home security system so great it is
always ready simply safe could cost an
arm and a leg but you know what it
doesn't instead the only Chad you you
know they only charge you what's what's
fair sorry
24/7 professional security monitoring is
just $14.99 a month it's only a dollar
less than the [ __ ] barstool event
rough and rowdy
look at that cross-promoting there are
no contracts no hidden fees I recommend
simply safe to everyone I know
you gotta check it out go to simply save
burg calm that simply save burg calm to
protect your home and family today
simply safe burg calm and lastly but not
leastly our old friends they've been
with us since the beginning this might
be of my first advertiser as if I can
remember and they've never had a [ __ ]
problem
alright salt of the earth
stamps.com create your stamps calm
account in minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long term
commitments click print mail and you're
done
keywords and descriptors convenient easy
reliable efficient
stamps.com brings all am I supposed to
work those in stamps.com brings all the
amazing services of the US Postal
Service right to your fingertips by or
you tell us if you don't have any arms
ever see those people with born with no
arms how flexible they're shooting bows
and arrows they can use this [ __ ] to buy
and print us official what buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package any class of mail using your own
computer and printer stamps comm makes
it easy they'll send you a digital scale
automatically calculates the exact
postage stamps comm will even help you
decide the best class of mail based on
your needs no need to lease an expensive
postage meter and there are no long term
commitments I use stamps calm whenever
I'm sending out my posters I'm a [ __ ]
if I can figure out how to do it
damn it so can you alright when I use it
I really find it so easily conveniently
reliably efficient and right now
absolutely no negative references to the
post-office okay got it I will not say
one bad thing about the post-office and
right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com services with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale go to
stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in birth at
stamps.com enter ber right that right
there that was textbook [ __ ] an
advertising reading oh did I so anyway
so I watched the [ __ ] f1 race
congratulations to max Verstappen
congratulations to the Ferrari team I
don't know what the [ __ ] going on in
the pits I hope that guy from Ferrari is
alright you know we broke his leg what's
his face what the [ __ ] his name
Kimi something or other Kimi rigatoni
the other guy in the [ __ ] Ferrari
team I thought I thought I [ __ ] knew
his name anyways he comes in for a pit
stop and they've been having all these
problems like the Haas team both their
cars left the previous race in Australia
sorry I'm taping the scene here they
and went to go change the tires and they
didn't get him on properly and they left
and the cars were unsafe they both got
knocked out
Oh Kimi räikkönen he came in for a pit
stop they didn't put the right rear one
on right or they didn't get it on in
time or and they thought it was done I
don't know what the guy with the jack
let's the [ __ ] car down I don't know
who [ __ ] up there's like 40 people
that run up to the car and they're all
dressed exactly the same and when he
went to drive out the guys [ __ ] that
giant back rear tire went right over
this guy's [ __ ] foot and leg and you
know and he's sort of peeling out too so
Jesus Christ so that knocked their car
out of the race
Lewis Hamilton had a great race started
at ninth got all the way up to 3rd got
to the podium what's-his-face max
Verstappen accidentally crashed into him
or whatever in Lewis Hamilton once again
[ __ ] whining about it said max is a
[ __ ] it was a [ __ ] move he
wasn't showing him any respect out there
it's like Lewis he's doing what you did
when you came up what's he supposed to
do bit oh my god that's Lewis Hamilton
I'm not gonna try to beat him through
this [ __ ] turn I don't know what
problem what he did and neither did the
judges so what's the problem he had this
whole [ __ ] thing were you saying you
know he's disrespectful was a [ __ ]
move and all of that yeah that guy that
guy is I totally respect him he's a
[ __ ] amazing driver but I swear to
god he doesn't win he [ __ ] he's
always bitching about something he finds
me a peyton manning early in his career
we had protection issues you know always
[ __ ] finger pointing no you know my
radio wasn't working it was very
difficult each eye to figure out we know
he's supposed to drive or not haven't
you done enough of these there's
somebody in front of you go get him
bill it's a little more sophisticated
than that he was on the mediums the
other guy was on the supersoft anyways
it was a great race I'm just [ __ ]
with Lewis Hamilton fans [ __ ] relax
I'm just [ __ ] around I know he's your
Beyonce and I would have to deal with
the [ __ ] the the Louis hive coming at
me I don't I make fun of Lewis Hamilton
because he is
the best the guy's the best Mercedes
last year was the [ __ ] best the last
couple years they bend the goddamn best
and I'm new to the sport so what am I
gonna do
am I gonna jump on the bandwagon I can't
I'm actually I'm rootin I root for Hoss
the American team we kink Kevin
Magnussen came in fifth place that's 10
points [ __ ] unfortunately our
other driver Romain like the lettuce
drogyn however you say his name he came
in 13th it was a great [ __ ] race and
I hate to say this ESPN to their
coverage of that race was [ __ ]
phenomenal it was phenomenal I gotta
kind of knock a little [ __ ] I gotta not
[ __ ] sports a little bit cuz they just
used to just follow the leader whoever
was leading they was just up there and
then while the racing was going on in
the back and fourth fifth sixth seventh
eighth like the level that ESPN 2 was
covering the race and showing that all
that passing and like you know when
anybody gets like it was a good driver
gets like it's some sort of penalty a
gearbox penalty or whatever and they
move back you don't get to watch him
come through the field in these past
years the way ESPN you know was
following Lewis Hamilton coming up it
was [ __ ] great
I loved the race and the granite I don't
know [ __ ] about racing and I watched it
on you know the back of somebody's
[ __ ] chair on a flight I could barely
tell how many laps were left so I
imagine I missed a lot of the drama but
I went back and I looked at that it's
just like max just happened you can see
he's gonna be one of those guys he's
probably gonna win a championship he's
really young he's a great driver he's
got balls you know it takes a lot of
balls to go into a turn with loose
Hamill to be like [ __ ] this guy at the
guy position could fam unfortunately you
know it [ __ ] up his car I don't know I
think Lewis is a little scared you know
he reminds me of it was like when I you
see that that interview when Milton
Berle is trying to get Richard Pryor to
[ __ ] you know stand down because
Richard Pryor has the nerve to [ __ ]
laugh at him and then Milton Berle does
that he goes I'll give you some advice
he goes pick you spots maybe
and then Richard goes alright sweetheart
yeah [ __ ] you would you invent comedy
you didn't go [ __ ] yourself I'm funny
too
that's how I filled max for snap again
he's a [ __ ] race car driver supposed
to [ __ ] get out of the way that's not
raised not racing anymore I was just
driving around I could [ __ ] do that
poor red ball team Jesus Christ
[ __ ] Daniel Ricciardo aka Ricky Rican
and he [ __ ] nice car just died for
Stefan after he tried to pass Lewis
Hamilton what he's tire went out is
different she'll get all [ __ ] up but
whatever that's opening that the doors
for the American Racing team hahaha we
were doing great in Australia too we
couldn't put tires on it was [ __ ]
hilarious watching our pit crew coming
out they were so goddamn nervous they
came out with like laces out energy but
it was a great race and on next week
everybody the MotoGP race I think is
next week yeah it is is it
no wait is it in two weeks was there
been another one today if there was one
today I [ __ ] recorded it hang on a
second hang on a second I was trying to
go to that one and after I do Nashville
I was trying to go down to Austin go to
the race I just I got a kid man I can't
[ __ ] do that if I was in Austin I
would do it but I'm not gonna fly out of
my way and not hang out with my kid what
am i a [ __ ] degenerate yes I'm not
that big a degenerate though
alright MotoGP come on load load load is
that bad my internet as I have said I
have to cheer it on come on you could do
it I took like Lamaze classes with my
[ __ ] Internet come on do it push push
you look so beautiful it's still loading
this is [ __ ] I I pay like I got to
get somebody I gotta get a tech nerd
over here you know but before they do
they got to wear a helmet with a
chinstrap so that jaw doesn't hit the
floor when they see how much I'm [ __ ]
paying a month for cable
you know said they'd help me out with
that I gotta take him up on it
red band told me he'd help me out with
that [ __ ] because he told me a story
said he went home to his parents house
and saw how much they were paying and
then called up there
provider and uh you know tore him a new
[ __ ] with his algorithm it's still
[ __ ] loading alright I give up I give
up whatever let's uh let's let's read
some [ __ ] question is for this week
by the way you know I gave up arguing
with my wife for Lent and I'm continuing
it and I'm gonna tell you right now I am
getting some wins I'm getting some wins
you know because what look I'm still
losing a lot all right but you know I
look I'm looking like a seven and nine
season I think that's what I'm
projecting at but you know I was like
[ __ ] Owens sixteen like the Browns
last year because I'm finding like
what's good about not losing your temper
is when you're right and if he can
somehow keep your wife on topic you're
actually gonna win you know I don't know
who knows no as I already know she's
already [ __ ] adjust in a game to my
new [ __ ] style why won't this [ __ ]
thing Loeb what is the [ __ ] problem
how much money do I have to [ __ ] pay
wait a second let me just bring my
energy back down bringing it back down
again it's not that big a deal all right
here we go come on
load load there it is oh there was one
today there was one in Argentina I got
to watch it I gotta watch it before
somebody tells me the [ __ ] results
I'll talk about this one on Thursday
nyeeehhh then I also have to watch the
the UFC even though I already know the
results there I gotta watch this [ __ ]
the big fight rose namajunas first
Johanna Johanna na indirect trick I say
right Johanna na Eun's right Rick you
know I know how to say that because I
listen to this [ __ ] Russian guy as I
say yeah I listen to this guy for like
an hour
it was rose namajunas verse your honor
Ian's a trick did you guys get that it
was once again the fight was rose
namajunas versus your honor
Ian's Isaac yo Anna Kendrick yo an Anna
at some point in her life she has to
meet [ __ ] Axl Rose so he can sing her
name right sorry
bogey woman is coming for you I don't
know what she was trying to say like the
boogeyman she probably read up on the
boogeyman I mean it's a second language
it's pretty good that she could come up
with that but that was oddly terrifying
when she was saying that boogey woman is
coming for you Oh like I know this
brought me back to when I was single is
like man I I remember I dated boogie
woman a couple of times you know one of
those women you break up with you don't
even go back for your stuff you just
like [ __ ] this you can have it man I'm
[ __ ] out of here goddamn witch
all right Des Moines Iowa Hillary Swank
a billary Swank just checking in on you
and giving you some ammo when you go
back to your advertisers of all the
podcasts that I listen to on a regular
basis your ad reads are the only ones
that I will not skip through yeah
exactly that's why I [ __ ] around through
them so you got to keep it entertaining
because there's nothing stopping you
from fast forward and through you know
understands that stamps calm you know
didn't nature's box they didn't get it
and those other [ __ ] [ __ ] blue apron
all right of all the parquet also how
many corn-fed asses do I need to get
into seats to get you to make a stop in
Des Moines Iowa I've been up there I was
up there in the last year I did a gig at
Iowa State I don't know if that's the
morning I'll get out of that give a [ __ ]
I'll go out there hippie music
blind-spot always something I learned
with drumming
that thrash the thrash drumbeat is the
same beat and like like shout music
basically it's just the band's they're
playing with how they phrased the music
on top is different punk thrash and
shout music there's a lot of [ __ ]
similarities and that's one to grow on
hippie music blind-spot dear Billy curve
bald I love your podcast and I'm coming
to see you in Denver thank you I love to
hear you talk about music and drummers
in particular alright I got somebody new
that I'm following on Instagram
Instagram I she just came up at my feed
and she blew me away what is it ah [ __ ]
the pocket queen and I thought it was
funny cuz I don't know if she's a Guns &
Roses fan or if it's just a coincidence
but you know rocket Queen Guns N'Roses
fan and then the pocket Queen and she's
just an amazing amazing drummer who's
having the time of her life when she
plays I think it's the underscore pocket
drummer but uh I started following her
and happy I know she's just a [ __ ]
amazing drummer so anyways plow ahead
here where is it I love to hear you talk
about music and drummers in particular
have you ever taken a listen to John
Fishman the drummer and fish I know
bunch of hairy hippies I get it you know
it's not that it's that their songs are
17 minutes long it's just such a [ __ ]
commitment I will say because of fish I
learned about the Little Feat album
waiting for Columbus so I do one at that
live album I do want to thank them for
that anyways people always put them in
the hippie music category but they
aren't the [ __ ] Mamas and the Papas I
don't mind the Mamas and the Papas my
mother loved them so when I listen to
them reminds me of driving around you
know in the car when I was a kid with my
mom they put on more sold-out shows and
consecutively my computer just died
[ __ ] alright they put out most shows
consecutively that msg than anyone ever
Wow
even when the Billy Joel huh and at any
rate love Ephesus family and go [ __ ]
yourself alright well give me a give me
a [ __ ] album that I can you know
that's a good jump off that I can get
into their [ __ ]
I saw them live from the early 90s at
the old Boston Garden they headlined the
spin doctors were there off their first
album little miss can't be wrong all of
that [ __ ] it was like a [ __ ] a grunge
thing I don't know what the [ __ ] it was
it was like overnight all of a sudden it
had just changed it was 1992 when I saw
him let me see if I can look that up see
if I could find that the whole lineup I
think I want to say WB CN was a part of
it let's see here
fish spin-doctors Boston Garden 1992
yeah
no way yeah October 30th I mean the
reason why I went there was because the
the sketch comedy group Alan the monkeys
had won the BCM comedy riot al del bene
Dane Cook Bobby Kelly were in it and
they performed there too and I got to
watch them perform at Boston Garden let
me see if they got the lineup this was a
semi Halloween theme Devil's Night one
set show at the WBC a new music concert
rock a Boston event it was fish first
show at the Boston Garden oh no way I
saw that show this is how old I am they
actually have to describe the Boston
Garden a historic basketball and ice
hockey arena built in the 20s with the
capacity of about 15,000 addition to
fish and the spin-doctors the level
levelers material issue Michael Penn
and a comedy troupe that include Dane
Cook Alan the monkeys performed between
there was called Alan the monkeys the
comedy troupe kamizuru okay we won't we
won't get into the rest of it anyways
plowing ahead yeah I saw them I guess
October 30 that's right that's right I
just started doing comedy right around
them was right when I met Patrice so
there you go so I've actually seen them
so there's a lot of like psycho fish
fans that would be like oh my god you
saw him for the first time at the Boston
Garden I saw one of their legendary
shows and had no idea who they were I
just remembered they had these little
workout trampolines personal trampolines
that they were jumping up and down on
the whole time and the crowd was jumping
with them and I thought they were cool
but I never really got into him all
right race documentary hi Bill I was
listening to your podcast where you
talked about your new interests in
MotoGP yeah it's [ __ ] I'm obsessed
with it you should check out this
documentary about the annual Isle of Man
TT race I was trying to go to that the
last two years and I can't get anybody
to go with me it's not MotoGP but it has
similar bikes I think yeah it's a yeah
it's it's a road race around the island
and more people have died than years
they've had it so I mean it's incredibly
dangerous I'd like to go see it see
people driving that fast but I don't
know watch somebody die either or die
myself with [ __ ] flying into the crowd
it's road racing instead of track so
there's no tire walls to crash into etc
it's insanely dangerous usually couple
riders are killed each year and this
documentary follows one of the riders
for one of the years I have only I only
have a passing interest in racing but
this illustrates the danger of the sport
really well in case the link doesn't
work the doc is called TT 3d closer to
the edge
loved the podcast you crack me up I
might even buy some of your [ __ ] you're
peddling I'm really not pet I don't sell
anything on my website alright so I
didn't need the little snide [ __ ]
comment o L maybe just talk about the
[ __ ] that I'm advertising in that case
[ __ ] how about it alright
evil woman evil woman dear Billy Hale
Bopp I don't get that oh my my [ __ ]
daughters up here I gotta finish this
thing all right I was watching the
documentary called wild wild country
with my girlfriend it's about a group of
followers of a guru from India who set
up shot shop in a remote town in Oregon
everybody's watching this right now I
won't get into the higher question of
what is a cult and what is a religion
I'll tell you the exact thing a cult is
a new religion a religion is a former
cult that took over that's the only
difference while watching my girlfriend
while watching my girlfriend didn't seem
as angry with a particular person as I
was the first in command under the Guru
was a woman named Sheila I don't want to
spoil the dog for you listener but she
did some evil [ __ ] in the name of her
cause oh yeah if she did she was a
[ __ ] lunatic like most guys who were
in power she acted accordingly
see and that's the thing right there
well they sit there and they act like if
women ran the world there would be no
war it's it's not it doesn't have to do
with sex most people if when given
powers do not handle it well they either
hurt other people they hurt themselves
they sabotage it because they can't deal
with the [ __ ] pressure well they just
become a [ __ ] like me she's a very
compelling person to hear and speak and
I understand how some of her might find
a charismatic I liked her to a point I
like that she was just like standing up
to everybody but then you know she went
too far she kind of went like you know
I'll [ __ ] kill everybody instead of
just the people she was upset with she
didn't try to hurt them she tried to
[ __ ] over everybody but when he get to
the part for that this six-part series
she started hearing about the town's
water supplies being poisoned under her
authority he goes on this is disgusting
isn't it no that's [ __ ] terrorism but
this is
you know what 25 years before 20 some
years before 20 years maybe before 9/11
so she was just considered a you know
[ __ ] I think my girlfriend started
giving me a hard time for calling this
Sheila a [ __ ] saying I worship guys like
Tony Soprano and Walter White
yeah he goes yeah I do I worship
fictional characters that they were but
I never defended waste-management
racketeering and lying to my family
about being a math chemist it ended with
her telling me that I'm biased towards
the achievements of men I can't deal
with this lack of rationale I'm
considering breaking it off with their
thoughts keep your calm and just say
listen the difference between me liking
you know anti-heroes in a movie versus
you liking an antihero that actually
existed and really poisoned to town you
just say listen if Tony Soprano Walter
Wright were real people I wouldn't be a
fan of them but you know you know you
like to surprise you your your you like
the characters you like the acting the
writing the way it's shot oh you know
Breaking Bad and all that that's that's
that's all that is if you're considering
breaking it off with it over this and I
would say you know I think you should I
mean if this is enough to make you break
it off you might as well you know just
you know I would drink your tap water
for a couple of months apparently I'm
controlling is the name of this yeah I'm
gonna say just by that title I'm gonna
say that you are apparently I'm
controlling like people always like it
called out on this [ __ ] with you know
it's like that bearded [ __ ] on the
Flyers every time he [ __ ] takes out
somebody's knee and every time he it's
like so blank what the [ __ ] he just did
it's like totally away from the pocket
complete penalty he always puts his head
I was like what the [ __ ] did I do dear
Billy bunghole I recently started dating
and everything was going so well so I
decided to invite her to a Mariners game
for opening weekend you know had I known
you were gonna say the name of the
baseball team I would have switched it
just in case
I don't know somehow somebody figures us
out anyways I knew she was a baseball
fan and would be excited to go I invited
her and she said that sounded really fun
so I was really excited as well I told
her I would take care of the tickets
because I knew finding tickets for
opening weekend would be hard so she
agreed and said she would pay for food
and drinks look at this everything's
going great so far it's like a classic
horror movie you know they get to the
[ __ ] Crystal Lake everybody's having
a good time and it's all enjoyable - the
first time they go cheat a couple of
days later she started having Trump car
troubles and was worried she couldn't
make it to the game because she wanted
to fix her car by Monday and the game
was on Sunday I live in the city and
don't have a car but offered to rent a
car to pick her up we could ride the bus
together since we would be drinking and
the bus draws people off right outside
the stadium she didn't answer my texts
for a couple days and told me less than
told me less than 24 hours that she
wasn't going to make it I sent her a
text back saying that I was upset about
it and that if we had just had a regular
day date scheduled I wouldn't mind what
the tickets weren't cheap front row
lower level outfield and I don't get to
go to many ball games that it's
important to me she didn't reply until
the next day and said she wants to stop
seeing me because the text seemed
controlling but I was honestly just
trying to tell her how I felt about
being ditched
I'm usually a pushover and this was the
first time I sent text like this before
so do you think that I was being
controlling that would appreciate some
advice thank you and go [ __ ] yourself PS
bring back the Sonics are you gonna get
a hockey team instead Sonic's on ice
calling the Seattle soliloquies no but I
understand both she has to get to go to
work on [ __ ] Monday she wants to make
sure car is alright I
get that this but to say that she you're
controlling and she wants to stop seeing
you I would say she dated a psycho
before and is a little gun-shy or she
wasn't that into anyways to quote Greg
Behrendt you know I hope you just went
to the game with a buddy or as it got
[ __ ] hammered yeah I don't know I was
just right back just say you know I
guess we had a miscommunication but I
have to admit if you know one little
spat like that it makes you think about
breaking up with me I kind of feel like
you're not that into me anyway so before
one of us really gets hurt
why don't we just let us just end his
friends and really try to end his
friends that is that is a skill I wish I
had and to end the way you end is
friends with somebody this is for men
and women is you just you have to be a
hundred percent honest with them you
know and if you have been honest with
somebody and you're in relationship
right now if you're really honest with
them now they're still probably going to
hate you but you still have to do it
because what you're doing now is you're
setting up healthy relationships in the
future all right so then you could just
got it all out there they knew from day
one from day one when you meet a woman
you knew what's what's going on between
us nothing I'm just you know I'm not
looking to be in a relationship right
now I'm just having fun that's it so
what you just want to have sex with me
yes what you're gorgeous
I've attracted to you know I'll practice
safe sex do you want to get [ __ ] I'm
the man for the job you have to be that
honest alright anyways black girl
friends family hey Billy Bart peeps
guys are killing me today I'm a 25 year
old guy and I've been with my girlfriend
about eight months 25 year old I've been
with my girlfriend for about 18 months
sorry things are great between us and
she's awesome we're both single parents
of a four of four-year-olds are both in
school and both work decent jobs all
right I have to ask you this before we
go any further that night do you dress
up like a black woman I'm just you know
this is too many coincidences is this
like some [ __ ] psycho [ __ ] where is
your Norman and you're your mother no
all right I'll continue she's a great
mother a very sweet encouraging
beautiful woman who keeps herself in
great shape and is working on her
doctorate in nursing the total package
the only problem is her family bubble
boom Wow she's a black woman and I'm the
first white guy she's been with my
daughter is mixed and I'm used to dating
interracially and my parents and
brothers lover but with her family her
brothers and dad just don't like me they
barely speak to me even though we have a
lot of the same interests in sports
music etc this sounds like a like a
[ __ ] Ice Cube movie her mother
grandmother and sister love me and we
get along great but I plan on marrying
her and would like a good relationship
with the brothers and her dad they have
no reason to dislike me as I treat my
girlfriend very well and I've never
acted like an [ __ ] around them well
yeah you get judged probably by all the
white people and the [ __ ] that they've
done the only thing we can think of is
they don't like me because I'm white
because she said her it
she said her ex and them were cool and
even hooped together often
oh wait wait okay so her ex all day like
the other boyfriend better her brother
said to me a few weeks ago when I tried
to talk him and invite him to play ball
he said we got nothing to speak on
you're never gonna be my beef family it
came out of nowhere
before they were just cold to me I've
come across people being prejudiced to
me while hooping and in my area grew up
it's just weird because they actually
know me and know how much I care about
their sister any advice from you or the
lovely Nia on how to approach this
situation or if you've ever run into
this problem I'm saving up to buy her to
buy a ring and would like to rectify
this before committing the rest of my
life to her thanks for all the laughs
over the years and go [ __ ] yourself
that's a [ __ ] major issue that's a
major issue and and relationships are
hard enough forget about when one whole
side of the family doesn't like you I
would just use humor that's how I'd get
through it I go over Hospital ight guy
nobody likes and you guys want me to
stand outside while you talk to you your
daughter for her sister I don't know if
or it act extra white I go over there
dressed like in it with a Donald Trump
extra-long red tie I just started having
fun with it you know hey did you guys
see that of that [ __ ] great speech by
Trump I don't know see I'm a dick I
would probably start doing that but I
gotta be honest that's gonna wear on
Thanks I think I would pump the brakes
on the ring until you work that out and
I think you guys maybe you need help
beyond some dick joke [ __ ] comedian
[Music]
yeah because that sounds like that's
going in a direction where you're gonna
have to she's gonna have to make a
choice either be with you or have a
relationship with the family I don't
know but that's that's above my pay
grade so my advice to you is I would
talk to her about it
and you know I would tell us it listen
you know I'm ready to commit to you for
the rest of my life but like like I
don't know if I can I don't want to
commit
that because this is the thing you don't
marry her you marry her family and if
her family [ __ ] hate you dude you're
gonna be miserable
alright and haven't been with somebody
for as long as I have you know there's
ups and downs and [ __ ] even without that
unfortunately Nia's family is [ __ ]
awesome
so I lucked out there and even then
we've still had difficult times mostly
because I'm a [ __ ] idiot but yeah so I
would try to work that out alright yeah
what the [ __ ] are you in a rush for you
know you already have a kid okay and I
don't know I would just feel this is I'm
not going over you had they no [ __ ]
don't want me around they're your
[ __ ] you know I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
tired of going over there being like AE
well you want to [ __ ] hang out they go
yeah get the [ __ ] out of here so it's
just like alright I get it I get it but
there's no reason to be stubborn you
know about it it's weird because your
heart's involved but anybody with a
brain would be like well dude that's
gonna be a [ __ ] miserable marriage
you know yeah Jesus Christ and then what
they're gonna show up at the [ __ ] mat
at the wedding just [ __ ] mean mugging
you the whole time I'll tell you this if
you marry a [ __ ] elope that's the way
to do it you know I would go I would go
that right on out dude
see now you got to do all of this [ __ ]
now you got to do all of it it's already
hard enough you know dirty be hard
enough you get married it's already
gonna be hard enough and now you gonna
add that [ __ ] that [ __ ] I don't know but
you love her so I don't know what to
tell you gonna have to get help
alright I'm talking in circles alright
that's it I'm gonna watch that UFC in
that MotoGP I'll [ __ ] you know the
old news I don't give a [ __ ] I'll make
it funny I'll talk about on Thursday
have a great couple of days you [ __ ]
and I'll check in on you in a few days